[موسيقى]
احييكم وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا المساء
تقدمها لكم ميسون نويهد نبدا بالعناوين
روسيا ترحب بخطه السلام الصينيه مع تحفظات
وضغوط غربيه على
تاجيل بحث وضع القرم
يكون
يراجع سياسه بلاده في افريقيا لا قواعد
عسكريه فرنسيه وانما حضور ضمن قواعد دول
القاره
قانونيون اسرائيليون يحذرون النائب العام
افعال المستوطنين في بلده حواره قد ترقى
لجرائم حرب
بعد تقرير حكومي امريكي ان فيروس كورونا
خرج من مختبر صيني جمهوريون يطالبون
بمحاسبه بكين
[موسيقى]
الرئاسه التونسيه مشاهدينا رحبت بالخطه
كفكره لكنها لم تستلطف البنود واعتبرتها
بالمجمل عمليه طويله ومرهقه وان تفاصيلها
تفاصيلها يجب ان تخضع لتحليل دقيق
وحسابات نتابع
برشلونه
الرماديه يقول مسؤولون غربيون ثم انها
ايضا تتفادى المسائل الامنيه المعقده
بالنسبه لكاف اولا ثم موسكو او تؤجلها
للحوار الروسي الاوكراني الذي جرب وفشل
ايضا وهذا وفق التعليقات الاوروبيه على
هذه الخطه الروسيه
عام من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه توسطت
فيه كافه الاطراف الدوليه لوقف الحرب الا
انها لم تنجح لتعرض الصين في ذكرى الاولى
للحرب خططا باثني عشر بندا لاحلال السلام
بين الطرفين الاوكراني والروسي
[موسيقى]
الكريم وصف المبادره الصينيه بانها تستحق
الاهتمام منتقدا لظروف الراهنه التي تحول
دون تنفيذها
اننا ننظر في خطه اصدقاءنا الصينيين
باهتمام كبير انها عمليه طويله في الوقت
الراهن لا نرى الظروف التي من شانها ان
تضع هذه القضيه على مسار سلمي العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه مستمره
[موسيقى]
رحبت بحذر
بالخبط على بعض البنود وزيلينسكي اكد ان
فكره توسط الحليف في روسيا في السلام امر
مبشر
من الصواب الاعتقاد بانه اذا كانت هناك
افكار تتوافق بطريقه او باخرى مع احترام
القانون الدولي وسلامه الاراضي فلنعمل مع
الصين في هذه النقطه
كما انه عبر عن رغبته بلقاء نظيره الصيني
لمناقشه العمليات العسكريه والعلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
بكين من جانبها لم تعلن عن نيه مشابهه بل
اكدت انها ستكون على تواصل مع جميع
الاطراف لمناقشه خطه السلام المقترحه
مشيره انها علمت برغبه الزلينسكي للقاء
الرئيس الصيني لكنها لم تعلم كيف سيتم
اللقاء
تتخذ الصين موقفا واضحا للغايه وثابتا من
الازمه الاوكرانيه نحن على اتصال مع جميع
الاطراف المعنيه بما في ذلك اوكرانيا
الغربيه متفاوته قابلت المبادره الصينيه
بعضها كان مشجعا والاخر كان مشككا اما في
الولايات المتحده فقد شككت المخابرات
والبانتاجون بدور الصين بينما ترك البيت
الابيض الباب مفتوحا حول مساهمه بكين
بالحل لكن الابرز هي تسريبات صحفيه عن
توجه غربي للضغط على كييف للقبول
بالمفاوضات خلال اشهر وعمر العربيه
بالتزامن مع ذكرى التاسعه لضم روسيا شبه
جزيره القرم تهرب مستشار الامن القومي
الاميركي من الاجابه على سؤال ما عما اذا
كانت اداره بايدن ستدعم اوكرانيا بحاله
ربطت الفوز على روسيا باستعاده شبه جزيره
القرم سولفان قال ان واشنطن يجب ان تركز
حاليا على مساعده اوكرانيا في استعاده
المناطق على خط التماس اما مساله مصير شبه
جزيره القرم فستبحث في المستقبل تصريح
سالب عن هذا فسره البعض بان الحرب في
اوكرانيا ستطول اكثر من المده المتوقعه
لنتحدث اكثر عن هذه الخطه الصينيه او
المبادره الصينيه تنضم الينا من موسكو
مراسله العربيه كاتيا مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بكما سابدا معك كاتيا كيف تتلقف
روسيا هذه الخطه او المبادره الصينيه
المكونه من 12 نقطه
مرحبا من ميسون بالفعل الكريم اليوم كان
قد علق على هذه الخطه التي او الوثيقه
التي قدمتها الصين بشان مبادر سلامه حول
اوكرانيا كانت تاكدت انها ان موسكو
لاهتماما كبيرا لهذه الوثيقه وانه يجب
دراسه هذه النقاط الاثنى عشر بالتفصيل
ويجب تحليلها بشكل كامل لان خطه السلام
بشكل عام ستكون
حدثت فتكون صعبه بسبب تواجد عده اطراف في
هذه الازمه ولكنه عاد انه واكد طبعا
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الكرملين كان قد اكد
انه حتى الان لا يوجد اي بوادر تشير ان
الى ان الجانب الاوكراني هو ينوي الجلوس
الى طاوله المحادثات مع اجانب الروسي
وبالتالي روسيا ستتابع بهذه العمليه
العسكريه التي بداتها في اوكرانيا حتى
تحقيق جميع الاهداف التي بداتها ايضا كان
هناك تصريح للخارجيه في وقت رحبت به
الوثيقه الصينيه للسلام التي تتالف من 12
بندا كانت قد تحدثت ايضا المتحدثه ماريا
زخرفه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه كانت قد قالت
انها موسكو ترحب بهذا الاقتراح الذي طبعا
هو جاء على من الجانب الصيني بعد زياره
الدبلوماسي الصيني الذي شهدناها خلال
الاسبوع الماضي الى موسكو ولقائه لرئيس
الروسي
ووزير الخارجيه الروسي سميسون بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا حذيفه ايضا كيف تنظر الى هذه
المبادره المبادره هل تعول عليها ما هي
ابرز المواقف الرسميه تجاهها
نعم تحياتي ميسون لكاتيا هذه المبادره على
الرغم من انها وجدت استحسان في بعض النقاط
الا انها وجدت انتقادا واسعا من المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين زانيه لشكا
القائمه بالاعمال في بكين الاعمال
الاوكرانيه في بكين رحبت بهذه المبادره
ولكن ايضا عاده وانتقدتها بعد ذلك وتحدثت
عن ان المبادره لم تحتوي على بند
لانسحاب القوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه كذلك قالت ان بكين لم تتشاور
مع كيف قبل ان تنشر هذه المبادره هذا من
جانب الرئيس فلاديمير زيليسكي على الرغم
ايضا انه قال ان هنالك نقاط ايجابيه ونتفق
مع بكين فيها ويجب ان نعمل على هذه النقاط
الايجابيه الا انه ايضا قال ان هنالك نقاط
نختلف مع بكين فيها وبعد ذلك ايضا عاد
وقال ان اي مبادره لا تتضمن انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه هي غير
مناسبه بالنسبه لنا ايضا ديفيد ارقامها
وهو رئيس فصيل خادم الشعب اي حزب الرئيس
فلاديمير زيليسكي ايضا انتقد بشكل كبير
هذه المبادره وقال ان المبادره لم تتضمن
بنت حول انسحاب القوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لذلك لن تجد هذه المبادره
استحسان الاوكرانيين ايضا عاد وانتقد
بكينا التي التي لم تصوت في مجلس الامن
على صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه وايضا قال ان
بكين يبدو انها تعمل في محاباه للاتحاد
الروسي وشكك طبعا في نوايا بكين في هذه
المبادره ايضا بعد ذلك ميخائيل بدولاك
انتقد هذه المبادره بشكل كبير جدا وقال ان
اي وقف لاطلاق النار
والحديث عن اعاده ترسيم الحدود وهنا في
اشاره للمناطق التي
روسيا قد ضمتها بالفعل اليها
بالمناطق الانفصاليه الاربعه اقاليم قال
واعاده ترسيم الحدود هذا امر غير مقبول
تماما وهذه
لاوكرانيا وهذا لا يعني نهايه الحرب وانما
تجميد الحرب مؤقتا بعد ذلك ستعود والمره
القادمه
ستعود سيعود الاتحاد الروسي لاباده
الاوكرانيين لذلك هذه المبادره لن تجد اي
قبول من الجانب الاوكراني الجميع اتفقا
حول ان مبادره بكين لم تتضمن البند
الاساسي بالنسبه للاوكرانيين وهو انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
كامل الحدود الاوكرانيه المعترف بها دوليا
ثم بعد ذلك الجلوس والحديث عن اي يعني
نقاط طبعا النقاط الاساسيه التي وجدت
استحسان الاوكرانيين طبعا البند الاول
الذي تحدث عن سلامه احترام سياده الدوله
وسيادتها على اراضيها هذا جانب ايضا طبعا
البند الذي تحدث عن
يعني المحطات النوويه ووضع السلامه في
المحطات النوويه ايضا عمليه تصدير الحبوب
الى العالم كذلك مساله التبادل التجاري
والاقتصادي وهنا طبعا البعض المراقبين
ينظرون الى مصلحه في ذلك طبعا لانه بكين
ايضا لديها كثير من التبادل التجاري مع
الاتحاد الروسي وكذلك مع اوكرانيا وفي
المنطقه وقد توقف كل ذلك بسبب هذه الحرب
لذلك وجدت اي نعم بعض الاستحسان ولكنه
وجدت ايضا انتقادا واسعا شكرا لك حذيفه
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل كنت معي
من كاف كما اشكر زميلتنا كاتيا طعمه على
ايضا التفاصيل حول المواقف الروسيه تجاه
هذه الخطه الصينيه شكرا لكما
في ردود الفعل الغربيه ايضا على الدوري
الصيني قالت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
كاترين كولونا ان على الصين
محذره في نفس الوقت من تقديم اي دعم عسكري
لروسيا
اسباب لارسال عدد معين من رسائل التحذير
الى الصين لقد فعلت ذلك بنفسي مع نظير
السابق الذي كان في باريس قبل اسبوع
وتمكنت من التحدث معه عن كل القضايا
المتعلقه بالحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وحذرت بكين من دعم روسيا عسكريا كنت اتحدث
الى مسؤول من الصين التي ما تزال تتمسك
بدفاعها التقليدي عن مبادئ ميثاق الامم
المتحده وقد تمكنت من اخباره باننا كنا
نعتمد على الصين لتظل ملتزمه كما هي بشكل
عام بالاستقرار الدولي
من رياض ينضم اليه الهام لي الصحفيه
الصينيه السيد الهام اهلا بكم معنا ما هي
الاسس التي اعتمدتها الصين برايك عندما
قدمت هذه الخطه المكونه من 12 نقطه لحل
هذه الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لدعوتكم الكريمه وفي
الحقيقه اول مبدا او اول اساس
للمبادره مبادره الصين لاتجاه الازمه
الاوكرانيه هي
المبادئ الاساسيه
لميثاغا الامم المتحده بما فيها الاحترام
لسياده واعراضها واعراضي دوله معينه وايضا
التوقف عن اطلاق النار او وقف التوقف
الحرب وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني نظرا لجهود
الصين
للدعم لحل ازمه الاوكرانيه يكون هناك
التعهدات من قبل الجانب الصيني مثلا يعني
الحمايه عن على المنشات لطاقه النوويه
وايضا يعني تقدم تقديم للمساعدات لاعاده
الاعمار بعد الحرب او بعد الازمه
الاوكرانيه
هذه النقاط استحسان وخاصه عند اوكرانيا
ولكن هل لماذا الصين يعني لم
تتفاوض او لم تدخل تشرك اوكرانيا وروسيا
عندما قدمت هذه
الخطه حتى يكون هناك من امال كبيره تعقد
عليها ويكتب لها النجاح
نعم في الحقيقه يعني
بصراحه هذه المبادره مبادره مبدئيا لحل
الازمه الاوكرانيه في الحقيقه نعرف يعني
للازمه الاوكرانيه تاريخ طويل وايضا اسباب
عديده لذلك يعني هذه المبادره المبادره
صينيه
جاءت بشكل مبدئي لحل المشاكل او لوضع اساس
للمفاوضات الثنائيه عونا مفاوضات متعدده
للتراث اطراف وبين روسيا واوكرانيا وايضا
الدول الغربيه وحتى الولايات المتحده في
الحقيقه يعني كما نرى ان هناك يعني عدم
التطرق لانسحاب القوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولكن في الحقيقه يعني مكتوبه
في هذه البنود التوقف عن الحرب فحسب
المفهوم الصيني التوقف ان الحرب هذا
الموضوع الاساسي لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه
وايضا يعني المفاوضات او الحل سلمي هو
اختيار الوحيد لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه ففي
الحقيقه يعني هذا من ضمن المبادئ الاساسي
لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه وفيما يخص
بالاراضي المحتله من قبل قوات الروسيه
وايضا انسحاب نعم كان هناك من مواقف كان
للكرملين للرئيس بوتين لمسؤولين روسلي
ايضا المسؤولين الاوكران للرئيس لينسكي
ولكن هل تم الاتصال مع الجانب الصيني
وابدوا عن ما هي تخوفاتهم وما هو قبولهم
بهذه المبادره التي على اساسها يجب ان
تنطلق الصين
نعم طبعا يعني هناك تواصل مباشره بين
الصين وروسيا نظرا للعلاقات القويه بين
الجانبين وبالنسبه الى التواصل بين الصين
واوكرانيا في الحقيقه يعني حتى الان هناك
علاقه جيده بين الدولتين ولكن يعني اعتقد
عدم تواصل قبل اصدار او قبل تسدير هذه
المبادره هناك اسباب مختلفه اول شيء يعني
بالنسبه الى الحكومه الاوكرانيه فهناك دعم
مباشره عسكري من قبل الدول الغربيه ففي
الحقيقه يعني هناك
العقوبات الوحديه الجانب المفروض على
روسيا فبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني كان هناك
زياره من كبيره الدبلوماسيين من قبل الصين
الى روسيا واللقاء المباشره مع فراديميرا
بوتينغ رئيس روسي في الحقيقه يعني هذه كل
الجهود المبذوله من قبل
الصين من اجل حل الازمه الاوكرانيه
وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني حسب ما نرى طبعا
هناك الخلافات بين الصين واوكرانيا
[ضحك]
كيف يمكن للصين ان تقنع اوكرانيا بانها
على مسافه واحده بينها وبين الروس لانه
معروف الصين قريبه جدا من الروس بايجاز لو
سمحت
في الحقيقه
المفاوضات طويله المدى كما ارى وليس بشكل
سهل ولكن لازم هناك جهود مشتركه
لتحقيق المصالح المتكامله بين الصين وبين
الدول الغربيه وبين روسيا وبين اوكرانيا
يعني اذا نرى الى هناك المصالح المشتركه
فيكون هناك حل لهذه الازمه الازمه الممتده
يعني لتاريخ طويل شكرا لك من الرياض الهم
لي الصحفي الصينيه على المشاركه معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء
نبقى في ملفات الحرب باوكرانيا حيث قال
الرئيس بيلاروسيا الكزندور ان بلاده
بالشراكه مع روسيا قديره على تصنيع ما
تحتاجه من اسلحه رغم العقوبات
اود الاشاره الى انه على الرغم من ضغوط
العقوبات غير المسبوقه فاننا ننتج اسلحه
ومعدات عسكريه كافيه لاحتياجات الجيش
البيلاروسي ويرجع ذلك الى ان كل ما نحتاجه
من الاسلحه والحديد نحصل عليه بسهوله من
روسيا فيما يتعلق بالالكترونيات الدقيقه
والالكترونيات الضوئيه والبصريات وغيرها
فالفضل لاولئك الذين حافظوا على مرافق
الانتاج الموروثه من الاتحاد السوفيتي حيث
بامكاننا مع روسيا انتاج اي نوع من
الاسلحه
التغييرات التي احدثتها حرب اوكرانيا في
اوروبا ابديه واكثر عمقا من اي حدث اخر
مدن نهايه الحرب البارده عام 1989 صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز اكدت ان الحرب اسفرت عن
زعزعه غير مسبوقه للعقيده السياسيه في بعض
البلدان كالمانيا حيث ازاحت عقليه السلام
والحياد وافسحت الطريقه امام ادراك ضروره
القوه العسكريه لتحقيق اهداف امنيه
واستراتيجيه واعاده الاعتبار لجيوش مهمله
منذ عقود هذا وبدات الحرب الاوكرانيه
اوهام اوروبا بشان سياسه التواصل المعتاد
مع روسيا فهي ازاله الاقنعه وفق قول
الرئيس الفنلندي
ووصفتي الصحيفه الامريكيه لفتره الحاليه
بعصر اعاده الترتيب مضيفه انه لا عود
للوراء حتى بعد انتهاء الحرب فدول خرجت عن
حيادها ومدت اوكرانيا بالمساعدات العسكريه
واخرى اضطرت للتكيف مع قطع امدادات النفط
والغاز الروسي
[موسيقى]
في ظل العقوبات على روسيا ومع خروج كبريات
العلامات التجاريه الغربيه منها غزت
المنتجات الصينيه الاسواق الروسيه من
الهواتف الذكيه الى السيارات وغيرها
للتعويض هذا النقص شركات صينيه عده بينها
شركه الهواتف الذكيه شاومي وصانع السيارات
جيلي شهدت زياده في المبيعات خلال الاشهر
الاخيره فيما تراجعت مبيعات واجهزه ايفون
وسامسونج التي كانت تحتل المركزين الاول
والثاني من 53 الى 3% خلال العام الماضي
علما بان السلطات الروسيه سمحت بما يعرف
باسم الواردات الموازيه اي ادخال البضائع
من بلدان المجاوره مثل كازاخستان وان دون
ضمانات حرصا على التمسك بعلامات تجاريه
متميزه
[موسيقى]
في التاسعه هذا المساء نتابع بعد قليل
عقب زلزال مالاتيا انقذوا 32 عالقا من تحت
الانقاض
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد الرئيس
ضروره التعاون المشترك مع الدول الافريقيه
في المرحله المقبله ضمن واقع امني جديد
وسياسه اساسها الاحترام المتبادل
يجب النظر الى الدول الافريقيه كشريك
اساسي تربطنا به مصلحه مشتركه يجب خلق
علاقه جديده متوازنه ومسؤوله حان الوقت
لاعاده تحديد طبيعه علاقاتنا مع الدول
الافريقيه وعلينا ان نظهر تواضعا كبيرا
عندما نتعاون معها لدينا توجه جديد تجاه
القاره الافريقيه وسنتعامل مع واقع امني
جديد في افريقيا
ماكرون قال ان تواجد العسكري الفرنسي في
الدول الافريقيه سيكون عبر قواعد مشتركه
مع الدول ذاتها
لقد قمنا طوال السنين الماضيه بدعم
شركائنا في افريقيا وتم تكريس اكثر من
ثلاثه مليارات يورو بين عامي 2019 و2022
في اطار الدعم للدول الافريقيه نعمل على
سياسه جديده للتعامل مع الدول الافريقيه
وسيكون وجودنا في افريقيا عبر قواعد
مشتركه مع الدول الافريقيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم افاده وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
بمقتلهم مستوطن بجراح خطيره كان اصيب
بجراحا خطيره بعد عمليه اطلاق نار جديده
في ارحاب بدوره قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
ان حكومته ستقنن وضع المستوطنات التي ظلت
صغيره شرعيه لسنوات طويله واضاف نتنياهو
ان حكومته ستبني الاف المنازل في
المستوطنات كردا على الهجمات التي يتعرض
لها المستوطنون مشيرا الى انه لن يتم
اقلاع والاسرائيليين من تلك المواقع على
حد وصفه
اكدت 22 خبيرا اسرائيليا في القانون
الدولي على ان افعال المستوطنين في الضفه
الغربيه ترقى لجرائم حرب وفق صحيفه
بلدات في الضفه اسهر عن عشرات المصابين
ليدعوا الخبراء الى يدعوا الخبراء الى
تحقيق فوري في تلك الممارسات متهمين قاده
اقصى اليمين بالتحديد على العنف
ما محطه الطائره التي تقل الوفد الفلسطيني
القادم من قمه العقبه في رام الله حتى
اشتعلت الارض في نابلس
المستوطنون بالمئات يهاجمون القرى
والبلدات الفلسطينيه قتلوا شابا فلسطينيا
واصابوا العشرات بجروح احرقوا عشرات
المنازل والسيارات
[موسيقى]
هجوم المستوطنين غردته تصريحاتهم لوزراء
في حكومه نتنياهو وزير الماليه والمسؤول
عن اداره شؤون الاحتلال في الضفه
على تغريده لرئيس مجلس المستوطنات في
الشمال والذي يطالب بحرق مزيد من القرى
الفلسطينيه اما بنجافير فقال انما حدث في
قمه العقبه سيبقى في العقبه وتوجه لدعم
مجموعه من المستوطنين اعادوا بناء بؤره
استيطانيه جنوبي نابلس فيما طالب نتنياهو
المستوطنين بعدم اخذ الثار من عمليه حواره
التي ادت لمقتل اثنين من المستوطنين
بايديهم وان الجيش النظامي هو من سيفعل
ذلك
صامك خطبته الجيش الاسرائيلي وقوات الامن
تقوم حاليا بملاحقه القاتل سوف نعثر عليه
ونقبض عليه ونصفي الحساب معه اطلب منكم
حتى عندما يكون الدم فائرا والغضب كبيرا
الا تاخذ قانون بايديكم اتركوا الجيش وقوى
الامن تقوم بعملها
[تصفيق]
السلطه الفلسطينيه في موقف محرج للغايه
فهي التي توجهت لقمه العقبه للاجتماع مع
وفد اسرائيلي لبحث سبل التهدئه رغم
الانتقادات الشعبيه والسياسيه المحليه
وجدت نفسها تطلق قنابل الغاز على مجموعه
من المتظاهرين في نابلس حاولوا احراق مكان
يعتبره اليهود مقدسا كما انها تعجز عن
توفير الحمايه لمواطنيها الذين يتعرضون
لاعتداءات المستوطنين نتائج قمه العقبه
السي
اسيه قد اسرائيل منقسمه بين مجتمع مدني في
تل ابيب يتظاهر لاصلاحات قضائيه ودوله
مستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه يقودها وزراء
متطرفه اما الفلسطينيون فينقسمون بين سلطه
تحاول تغليب الحكمه السياسيه والتماشي مع
الاراده الامريكيه وشارع يخوض مواجهه
يوميه مع المستوطنين والجيش الاسرائيلي
نتائجها دماء عبد الحفيظ جعوان العربيه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
تحدثت مصادر مصريه للعربيه عن ان القاهره
تجهز لزياره مرتقبه للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان الى مصر في النصف الثاني من
العامه كما انه تم تحديد مباحثات بين مصر
وتركيا في شهر ابريل المقبل لرفع التمثيل
الدبلوماسيه بين القاهره وانقره مصادر
العربيه اكدت ايضا ان وزير خارجيه تركيا
سيزور القاهره قريبا
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود
شاويش اوغلو انه من المحتمل ان يعقد
اجتماع بين الرئيسين التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان والمصري عبد الفتاح السيسي خلال
الفتره القادمه واثناء لقاء مناظيره
المصري سامح شكري في ميناء مرسين اكد
الوزير التركي ان انقر ستعمل على نقل
العلاقات مع القاهره الى مستوى اعلى
نقوم بفتح صفحات جديده مع مصر وسنعمل على
نقل العلاقات مع القاهره الى مستوى اعلى
في الاونه الاخيره كانت هناك مباحثات بين
الرئيس اردوغان والرئيس السيسي
وتباحثت اليوم مع سامح شكري بشان الخطوات
التي علينا اتخاذها لتطوير العلاقات بين
بلدينا وتطور العلاقات التركيه المصريه
سيؤثر ايجابا على المنطقه باكملها
من جانبه قلا وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح
شكري انه يحمل رساله تضامنا الى تركيا بعد
الزلزال الذي ضرب البلاد
المحمل برساله
تضامن مؤازره ومواساه الى الشعب التركي
الصديق
على مستوى القياده
والحكومه والشعب المصري
لهذا المصاب وهذه الكارثه التي تالمنا
جميعا
لوقعها
نعمل بكل ما لدينا من جهد لمؤازره اخواتنا
واخواتنا في
تركيا
لتجاوز هذه المحنه
[موسيقى]
في تركيا ايضا لكن بموضوع اخر اعلنت اداره
الكوارث التركيه في بيان لها عن رصد زلزال
بقوه 5.6 درجه ضرب مناطق شرق تركيا ما ادى
الى مقتل شخص واصابات عده جراء انهيار
مباني في ملاطيا فيما اعلنت وسائل اعلام
عن انقاذ اكثر من 30 مدنيا من تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هو من ضواحياتها ينضم الينا مفرد العربيه
عبد القادر خربوش عبد القادر اهلا بك معنا
مال جديد حول زلزال الذي ضرب مالاتيا خاصه
بانه هناك كانت تهدم للكثير من المبانين
ماذا عن الاضرار
فعلا اخر حصيله كان اعلن عنها نائب رئيس
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه هي مقتل
شخص واحد واصابه 110 اشخاص بجروح فيما تم
انقاذ 32 شخصا من تحت الانقاد من بينهم اب
وابنته كان عالقين تحت بنايه فيما كان تم
الاعلان عن عدد البنايات التي انهارت
والتي بلغت تسعه وعشرين بنايه دمرت اثر
هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب ملاطها اليوم
ظهر اليوم بدرجه 5.6 على سلم ريختار هذا
الزلزال احدث حاله جديده من الهلع طبعا
ولكن اداره الزلازل والكوارث كانت قد وضحت
بانه سيتوقع ان تكون هناك هزات اخرى من
هذا من هذه الشده تحديدا فيما تم رصد اكثر
من 600 عنصر من اجل اغاثه واسعاف من كانوا
تحت الانقاض تم تحديد خمسه بنايات تحديدا
سقطت وكانوا تحتها عالقين لحد الان لا
ندري ان كان لا يزال هناك عالقين نرتقب
يعني صدور بيان جديد او تصريحات جديده
للاداره فيما لا يزال عدد اجمالي القتلى
اثر هذا الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب المنطقه
منذ السادس من فبراير
بلغ الاربعه واربعين الف قتيل وثلاثمائه
واربعه وسبعين شخصا انا الان في هذا
المخيم ميسون يمكن الحديث الان عن ما
يشاء واحد من
نعم في هذا المخيم هناك 414 خيمه يعيش في
هاته المدينه من الخيام هي مدينه صغيره
الفي شخص كلهم نجوا من الزلزال لديهم قصص
لديهم عائلات فقدوهم تحت الانقاض هناك من
فقد بيته افراد عائلتهم الان او يحاولون
ان يتكيفوا في حياه جديده لم يتعودوا
عليها في الخيام نشاهد يعني يقومون بجلسات
سمر هناك تدفئه حسب ما يبدو من الخيام
يستخدمون خلالها الحطب هناك ايضا حتى
الالعاب مخصصه للاطفال في جانب اخر هناك
حركيه وكانه الحياه عادت من جديد حتى وان
كانت داخل هذه الخيام اقامتهم هنا قد تطول
وقد لن تطول لا ندري مرتبط هذا الامر
بدرجه
الجهات الحكوميه التركيه في تشييد
البنايات التي وعدت بترشيدها على الاقل
البنايات الجاهزه حيث اعلن اليوم الرئيس
التركي طيب رجب اردوغان التزامه بتوفير
على الاقل 16 الف منزل متنقل من الحاويات
التي يتم تجهيزها لتكون منازل مؤقته لاواء
المتضررين على الاقل في اليمن فيما التزم
ايضا
ببناء عدد من
39 الاف من المنازل في المناطق التي مستها
الزلازل وهي 12 ولايه وهذا الاعلان جاء
بعد انتهاء من الاجراءات المسح المبدئي
التي حيث تم رصد 185 الف مبنى متضرر سواء
انهار او متضرر ويجب ان يهدم في اسرع وقت
اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
مفرد العربيه الى هاتاي عبد القادر خربوش
وايضا في خبر متعلق بسلسال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا تتخوف اليونان من تداعيات الزلزال
الذي ضرب هذه المناطق في السادس من الشهر
الحالي محضره من موجات جديده من اللجوء
قادمه عبر حدودها مع تركيا تحرك السلطات
اليونانيه جاء السريعا حيث عززت اجراءات
لها الامنيه واللوجستيه على طول حدودها
البريه والبحريه مع تركيا وازادت قوات حرس
الحدود بمئات العناصر الاضافيه كما كثفت
من دورياتها على طول الحدود البريه مع
جارتها تركيا ويتوقع حدوث موجه هجره
جماعيه بالنسبه لكثير من الاشخاص الذين
ليس لديهم ماوى بسبب هذا الزلزال المدمر
في التاسعه هذا المساء نتابع بعد قليل
بريطانيا تتوصل لاتفاق مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي حول ايرلندا الشماليه ضمن اتفاق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تعهداتنا الامريكيه متكرره
بالدفاع عن الجزيره التايوانيه في حال
اقدمت الصين على غزوها ولكن السؤال هل
واشنطن قادره اصلا على تنفيذ وعودها تجاه
تايوان خبراء عسكريون امريكيون اجابوا على
هذا الاستفسار وحذروا من عدم استعداد
بلادهم لمواجهه حرب المحتمله مع الصين في
ظل افتقارها للصواريخ بعيده المدى
فالقاذفات الامريكيه مشاهدينا ستحتاج بين
الف و1200 صاروخ طويل المدى مضاد للسفن
للبقاء على مسافه امنه نسبيا فيما المخزون
الامريكي الحالي [__] اقل من 250 صاروخا
ومع الدعم الامريكي العسكري الضخم لكياف
وبمعدل الانتاج الراهن سيصل البنتاجون
الكميه المطلوبه بحلول عام 2035 على اقل
تقدير فاذا تامين الصواريخ مستحيل هذا
وحتى الخبراء واشنطن على النظر في وضع
الذخائر مسب في تايوان لصعوبه امدادها
لاحقا خلال الصراع على عكس اوكرانيا صحيفه
البريطانيه نقلت عن منتدى المحيط الهادئ
سيناريوهين مرعبين لتداعيات سقوط تايوان
في ايدي بكين تحت عنوان العالم بعد سقوط
تايوان سابدا بالحديث عن السيناريو الاول
بماذا يتمثل يتمثل بسقوط تايوان دون قتال
شامل وايضا دون مساعده دوليه وبموجبه تدخل
في محادثات سلام لكن الغزو الصيني يستمر
اثناء المفاوضات لحين سقوطها بالكامل اما
السيناريو الثاني فيشمل سقوط تايوان بعد
معركه داريا ضمت متاخره واشنطن وايضا
حلفائها حينها يكتشف التحالف ان الجيش
الصيني اكثر قدره من الروس في اوكرانيا
ويتكبت خسائر ماديه وبشريه مهوله لكن
سقوط تايوان باي طريقه من الطريقتين وفق
التقرير سيحمل وقعا كارثيا على الولايات
المتحده وايضا على مصداقيتها فحينها سينظر
للصين على انها محرك اساسي واقوى دوله
بالعالم
[موسيقى]
الكشف عن منشا فيروس كورونا عدا ليطرح
المزيد من الجدل ويزيد من حده التوتر
الحاصل بين الصين والولايات المتحده
وتحديدا
الجمهوريين الذين يرون بان محاسبه الصين
بات الضروريه بعد ان كشف تقرير امريكي بان
الفيروس تسرب من مختبر صيني نتابع
جوله جديده من العراق السياسي سببها هذه
المره تقرير حكومي امريكي حول منشا فيروس
كورونا من انه خرج بسبب حادث من مختبر
صيني في وهران وفق تقرير لموقع اكسيوس فان
الكشف عن منشا كورونا زاد من حده التوتر
بين الولايات المتحده والصين وطرح تململا
واستياء كبيرين في اوساط الاعضاء البارزين
في الحزب الجمهوري الذين لطالما وجهوا
اصابع الاتهام حيث يرون بان النتيجه التي
تم الكشف عنها من طرف مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الامريكي تثبت انهم كانوا على
حق طوال الوقت الماضي بخصوص تسرب الفيروس
من مختبر صيني لم يكن عن قصد ولم يكن ضمن
برنامج عسكري تعمل عليه بكين وانما بسبب
حادث لم تتضح اسبابه بعد لكن التقرير يطحن
كل النظريات التي تزامنت مع الجائحه والقى
باللوم على الصين بانها وراء الوباء ما
يفتح الباب مستقبلا للمحاسبه والتعويض بعد
التقرير ارتفعت الاصوات المطالبه بالسياسه
اكثر صرامه مع الصين بدفع من الخلافات
التي تشهدها العلاقات بين واشنطن وبيكين
كل ذلك والصين ترفض الاتهامات لكنها وحتى
الان لم تقدم اي تفسير او دليل على مصدر
الفيروس
ينضم الينا الزميل بيرغانم وناسه العربيه
اهلا بك معنا ما مدى صحه هذا التقرير
ودقته
هذا تقدير لوزاره الطاقه الامريكيه ما حدث
هو ان الرئيس الامريكي طلب من كل الوكالات
والوزارات المعنيه اعداد موقف وتقدير
لمصدر الفيروس وكانت وكاله المكتب الاتحاد
التحقيقات الفيدرالي قال ان السبب هو تسرب
مختبر جاءت الان وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه
لتؤكد ما قاله مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
وقال ان الارجح انه
متسرب من مختبر ولكن يجب القول ان هذا
واحد من التقييمات او التقديرات وهو ايضا
على ثقه منخفضه وبالتالي ليس هناك ثقه
عاليه بمضمون هذا التقرير لكنه يزيد
الضغوط والشكوك لماذا هذا الجدل حول هذا
التقرير بالذات يعني منذ بدايه كورونا
وحتى الان هناك
العشرات حتى لا نقل من التقارير التي صدرت
ودائما كان الاتهام الاول تجاه الصين هذا
التقرير بذات لماذا يحدث كل هذا الجدل
خاصه في الاوساط الامريكيه بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين ايضا
اولا لان هناك شكوك ثانيا لانها
الامريكيين لا يثقون ان الصينيين يتعاونون
وليست هناك اجوبه واضحه من قبل بكين حول
ما حدث في هذا الفيروس هذه التناقضات مع
بعضها ودخول وزاره الطاقه الى جانب الاف
بي اي في التقدير ان هذا ياتي من مختبر
وليس من حارث بيولوجي عادي في احد اسواق
السمك في يوهان جعل هذا الموضوع عالي
الحساسيه وارتفعت الضغوط والاختلافات
هل نتوقع
الجمهوريون هل نتوقع من الجمهوريين حقيقه
ان يستغلوا هذا التقرير لتبيان بانه دائما
كانوا على حق منذ اليوم الاول بان الصين
وراءه حتى ولو كانت السيناريوهات مختلفه
ان كان من مختبر او من سوق
هناك نوع من غضب بشكل عام في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تجاه الصين هناك غضب
خاص من قبل الجمهوريين تجاه الصين وهناك
ايضا سبب سياسي لدى الجمهوريين لوضع
ضغوطات اضافيه على الصين وعلى الاداره
الامريكيه الديمقراطيه الحاليه وارتفاع
الاصوات الجمهوريه ضد الرئيس بايدن الطلب
منه ان يحقق اكثر ان تكون يده شديده اكثر
مع الصين هو احدى الاسباب الموجوده حول
هذه القضيه وجاء هذا التقرير ليشعل الفتيل
مره اخرى
اثبت الى الصين الصين ايضا اليوم تنفي هذا
الموضوع وتقول بانه دائما وتطلب من
الولايات المتحده ان تكف عن اتهامها في كل
شارده ووارده ودائما تختار موضوع كورونا
لتتهم الصين اتهامات باطله حسب الصين هذا
ايضا لن يصاعد بين الصين والولايات
المتحده وخاصه بان العلاقات اصلا متوتره
العلاقات متوتره بالفعل الامريكيون عندما
تسالنهم عن الصين
يطلبون منك اولا ان تعبر الصين عن مواقفها
بالنسبه لهم ما يريدونه هو بعض الالتزام
بالاصول الدوليه اولا احترام الحدود عدم
الوقوف الى جانب روسيا عدم تهديد امن
تايوان وطبعا تحدثي عن هذا الموضوع قبل
قليل في هذه النشره ثم يطلبون بشكل خاص ان
تكون الصين صادقه وانت تعاون بشكل ايجابي
للكشف عن مصدر هذا الفيروس السبب الاساسي
ليس فقط الصدق انما ايضا في محاوله صادقه
لتحاشي ماساه اخرى وموت الملايين كما حدث
في هذه الجائحه شكرا لك من واشنطن مراسله
العربيه على كل هذه التوضيحات والتفاصيل
ايضا في الملفات التنافسيه بين واشنطن
استفزت الحرب والاوكرانيه حروبا اخرى لا
تزال في نطاق المناوشات بين الصين
والولايات المتحده استفزازات اربكت الهادئ
وترت الصناعات وطرق الملاحه العالميه ورفع
درجه المنافسه للقصوى وعن القصوى نقصد
السباق على كسب الفضاء
قطعت حرب اوكرانيا الوصل الروسيه الاوروبي
والروسيه الامريكيه في مجال الفضاء لكنها
قربت المسافه اكثر مع الصين منافسي امريكا
الاول في برنامج اعاده البشر الى القمر
اذ كلف الصراع وكاله الفضاء الروسيه
شاركتها مع نظيرتها الاوروبيه
ففي ابريل علقت تعاونه في عده بعثات قمريه
ومشروع نوعي لارسال مركبه فضائيه الى
المريخ
خساره تكبدتها روسيا بعد تعليق شركه
الاقمار الصناعيه وانلمتد ومقرها لندن في
مارس الماضي جميع عمليات الاطلاق من منصات
اطلاق روسيه عزله روسيه وجدت فيها بكين
فرصه شراكه مهمه لمقاومه ضغوط امريكا في
فرض قواعد الاقتصاد الفضاء الناشئ لكن
البرنامج الروسي ليس في افضل احواله فبحسب
صحيفه
تراجع انتاج الفضاء الروسي الى الثلث في
اقل من عام رغم ذلك ترى الصحيفه ان
تعاوننا يظل ضروريا على مستوى تطوير اجهزه
استشعار فضائيه للكشف عن صواريخ بالستيه
وصواريخ فرط صوتيه
شراكه قد تفتح شهيه شركاء اخرين للانضمام
لسباق الغزو الفضائي بين الولايات المتحده
والصين التي لا تزال امريكا فيه المتصدر
الاول فامريكا تمتلك حصه الاسد من الاقمار
الصناعيه الناشطه التي تدور حول الارض
نتحدث عن نحو ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه قمر
صناعي امريكي الصين في المرتبه الثانيه
بعدد لا يتجاوز 600 قمر صناعي وروسيا التي
تحاول اللحاق بالركب ب 172 قمرا صناعيا
حتى الان لا توجد اليه دوليه تعالج
الجرائم او المخالفات الفرديه خارج الكوكب
لذا فان شرطي الفضاء القادم من يسن
القواعد ويضع المعايير قد يكون هو نفسه
شرطي العالم الجديد في وقت قريب جدا كرمح
النووي العربيه
[موسيقى]
نبقى في اسيا وفي ظل تقارير متزايده عن
نقص خطير في الغذاء بكوريا الشماليه اثار
اجتماع اللجنه المركزيه لحزب الزعيم كيم
جونغ اون تساؤلات عن حجم الازمه فبالعاده
تعقد مثل هذه الاجتماعات مره او مرتين في
السنه لكن الاجتماع الماضي لم يمضي عليه
شهران وركز هو الاخر على القضايا الزراعيه
وزاره التوحيد في كوريا الجنوبيه اورد
التقارير عن وفيات بسبب المجاعه في جارتها
المعزوله مرجحه طلب بيونجي لمساعده من
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي على خلفيه النقص
الكبير بالغذاء وتواجه كوريا الشماليه
المسلحه نوويا صعوبات منذ فتره طويله في
توفير المواد الغذائيه اثر العقوبات التي
زادتها حده جائحه كورونا واغلاق الحدود
علما ان كوريا الشماليه تعرضت لعده مجاعات
ادت احداها في التسعينيات لمقتل مئات
الالاف
[موسيقى]
الى اوروبا وتحديدا بريطانيا توصل رئيس
الوزراء لبريطاني ريشيسوناك ورئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه الى اتفاق يضع حدا
لخلافهما في شان عمليات المراقبه لمرحله
ما بعد بركزيد في ايرلندا الشماليه وقال
سوناك ان الاتفاق يحمي سياده ايرلندا
الشماليه مشيرا الى ان بريطانيا فتحت صفحه
جديده مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
اتفاقنا اليوم مع الاتحاد الاوروبي يحمي
سياده ايرلندا الشماليه ويمنع وضع حدود
بين ايرلندا الشماليه وجمهوريه ايرلندا
بما يؤول الى ازاله كل عقبات نقل البضائع
التجاريه بين ايرلندا الشماليه وجمهوريه
ايرلندا كما نود الاشاره الى انه سيتم
تطبيق قانون الاتحاد الاوروبي في ايرلندا
الشماليه لتفادي وضع حدود في الجزيره
وازاله اي حدود بحريه في البحر الايرلندي
بشان العلاقه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
بريطانيا فتحت صفحه جديده في العلاقات معه
لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق في اطار عمل يفرض
تسويه جديده فيما يخص ايرلندا وايرلندا
الشماليه اطار العمل سيكون بدايه لفصل
جديد بيننا ويؤمن حلولا طويله الامد والتي
ستناسب الجميع في ايرلندا الشماليه
[موسيقى]
والان الى موضوع يشغلنا كثيرا حقيقه وهو
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو يهدد الذكاء البشري
ويضعه في خانه الخطر وهذا ما وصلت اليه
تحذيرات عده بشان استخدام برنامج الدردشه
الالي
وهو الذي يشغل العالم فاخر استخدامات هذا
التطبيق اتحتها مؤسسات تعليميه للبكالوريا
الدوليه للطلاب في كتابه مقالاتهم وبحسب
صحيفه جارديان البريطانيه احتماليه الغش
المستند الى
ازعجه المعلمين
والاكاديميين ممن يعتبرونها خطرا على ذكاء
الطلبه البكالوريا الدوليه التي سمحت بهذا
التطبيق الذكي واجهت الانتقادات بتشبيه
السرقه الادبيه في البرنامج بالتعامل مع
الغشاشين واضافت ان الطلاب سيقتبسون من
المحتوى الذي
ويستخدمون مهاراتهم لتقييم النص واجراء
تعديلات قد فاتته ياتي ذلك وسط تحضيرات من
ان يسهم الروبوت بزياده انتشار المعلومات
الزائفه وايضا بالتلاعب بالراي العام يذكر
ان هي تقنيه مجانيه طرحت في نوفمبر الماضي
وهي روبوت يستطيع الاجابه على اسئله بشكل
تفصيلي ودقيق كما يستطيع ايضا كتابه
موضوعات صحفيه كامله
[موسيقى]
تسببت اضرابات عماليه في المانيا
بالغاء جميع الرحلات الجويه او تحويل
مسارها
[موسيقى]
منح الرئيس الروسي بلادي بوتين الممثله
الامريكيه ستيفنسيجال وسام الصداقه
الروسيه وتربط علاقه صداقه بين بوتين
وسيجال منذ فتره طويله نتابع
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يمنح الممثل
الامريكي ستيفن سيغال اسامه صداقه
المعلومات الروسيه تقول ان الوسام بسبب
مساهمه سيجال في تطوير التعاون الثقافي
والانساني الدولي لكن لسيجال علاقه بروسيا
وبوتين شخصيا قبل الوسام ومنذ فتره طويله
فسيجال المولود في ابريل عام 1952 بولايه
ميشيغان الامريكيه يعد صديقا مقربا جدا
للرئيس الروسي ومدافعا قويا عن سياساته
كما حصل على الجنسيه الروسيه في نوفمبر
2016 واستلم جوازه الروسي من بوتين شخصيا
رافق ايضا بوتين في عدد من فعاليات الفنون
الدفاع عن النفس
وفي عام 2018 عينت روسيا سيغال في منصب
ممثل وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه الخاص لشؤون
الاتصالات الانسانيه مع امريكا اما بعد
اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا وخلال حفل عشاء
بموسكو وصف سيجال بوتين بزعيم العالم الحر
واخيرا توجت هذه الصداقه الغامضه بين
بوتين بنظر محللين بوسام صداقه
ويبدو ان الزلازل لم تفارقنا هذا الشهر
زلزال بقوه 5.8 يضرب السيلفادور هذه المره
الى هنا تنتهي نشره التاسعه هذا المساء
نذكر بالعناوين
روسيا ترحب بخطه سلام الصينيه مع تحفظات
وضغوطات غربيه على تاجيل بحث وضع القرب
يراجع سياسه بلاده في افريقيا لا قواعد
عسكريه فرنسيه وانما حضور ضمن قواعد دول
القاره
قانونيون اسرائيليون يحضرون النائب العام
افعال المستوطنين في بلده حواره قد ترقى
لجرائم ح
رب بعد تقرير حكومي امريكي ان فيروس
كورونا خرج من مختبرا صيني جمهوريون
يطالبون بمحاسبه
[موسيقى]
اخبار العربيه لا تنتهي الان نستمر مع 360
والزميل طاهر ما هي ملفاتك اليوم طاهر
اهلا بك يا ميسون نحن سنركز على زياره
ماكرون الافريقيه سنتحدث عن تفاصيلها
وسنحلل ذلك مع ضيوفنا طبعا سنتناول ملفات
اخرى عديده متفرقه من حول العالم فارجو ان
تكون معنا